[Music]
Colten Underwood found in Portugal after
hopping the infamous fence I've been
through enough
but knowing I'm not enough for a long
time and every reminder of that just
makes me stronger something okay with it
night one of the bachelors two-part
season finale we saw the aftermath of
passing exit I didn't think it was
possible there to be a better connection
I'm not we have
[Music]
as Colton said to painful goodbyes to
Taoiseach Adams and Hannah Godwin I'm
saying goodbye to somebody who loves me
[Music]
sat down with both women on after the
final rose
but Hannah G is clearly still struggling
with the break-up I'm just hoping that I
can walk off of this stage with more
answers so I can sleep better at night
and finally live in the present and
Hannah seemingly called out Cassie
telling Colton she wouldn't have left
him I wouldn't have it was never an
option in my mind to not want to be with
you you have to choose to love somebody
and you have to choose to fight Spurs
anybody that you're in a relationship
with I think that's what love is and
that's what being in a relationship is
all about although there was still no
closure or any update on Colton's
current relationship status with Cassie
we will be seeing her on night two of
the finale
I can't wait to like be with family and
friends at home and you
move on with my life he spoke with
Colton last week after the women tell
all taping where he played coy on how
things end but did open up about the
empty ring box bachelor nation is dying
to know about got to ask you about the
empty ring box why is the ring box empty
Colton what does it mean where is the
ring I mean rings are meant to be on
finger it's not in boxes so so is the
ring on someone's finger was there ever
a ring in the box
yes sir within that box there's there's
been a regular that did you or Neil Lane
or someone put it in the box
yeah Neil Lane put it in that box that
was near lanes box so yes did you meet
me o lane during filming I have met Neil
Lane yes during filming yep during
filming so you looked at some rings well
how do you feel about how things ended
things haven't ended yet how do you feel
about how filming ended and where things
were at at that point emotional I mean
I'm in this emotional sort of Time Warp
right now so I'm reliving it with
everybody and it's been in charge it
hasn't always been easy filming wasn't
the easiest I have to do what feels
right and do it feels best for me
because I came here for love
and I love some money
[Music]
[Applause]